[Musica]
[Applauso]
esiste secondo voi un elemento chiave
differenziate che aiuta le persone a
raggiungere un obiettivo
ovviamente esiste più di uno ma dalla
mia esperienza ce ne è uno in
particolare che fa la totale differenza
che è il saper guidare il proprio
elefante
ora mi rendo conto che vi lascia un po
perplessi ma lasciatemi spiegare su
quella che ha un po la mia esperienza
sono un imprenditore e
ho a che fare tutti i giorni con
imprenditori professionisti sportivi
personaggi televisivi che hanno un unico
obiettivo che è quello di crescere hanno
un obiettivo molto molto chiaro ma al di
là di quello che è il piano di marketing
il piano di business
le attività che si devono fare con loro
c'è un elemento che fa la totale
differenza che è il coraggio di cambiare
ora sembra una banalità ma la verità dei
fatti è che quando sia a livello
professionale ma anche livello personale
siamo di fronte a un cambiamento
e tutti quanti abbiamo una stretta allo
stomaco se no sarebbe se fosse così
facile
chiunque che li volesse intraprendere
una dieta magari la conseguirebbe fino
alla fine magari ci scriviamo il
palestra per fare qualche chilo ma non
ci andiamo gli imprenditori provano
aggiunge risultati ma noi lo tengono
quindi cambiare è difficile e
personalmente parlando il mio più grande
cambiamento fu quando diventai papà per
la prima volta
cambiamento numero 1 diventavo genitore
non so voi ma io le istruzioni per
diventare genitore non l'avevo e quindi
ma il secondo cambiamento ispirato se
vogliamo da quella che è un po la mia
musa ispiratrice che a mia moglie era
quello di diventare un imprenditore e
quindi volevo regalare una libertà una
tipologia di lavoro di mestiere che
dovesse permettere di poter essere un po
più libero rispetto magari che un lavoro
da quello che facevo a livello economico
ma soprattutto a livello temporale per
poter decidere io i miei tempi e poter
stare con la mia famiglia e quindi cosa
feci definì un obiettivo e avevo
l'obiettivo chiaro e quando abbiamo un
obiettivo cos'è che facciamo
ragioniamo per facciamo un progetto
abbiamo magari obiettivi smart ci
mettiamo anche tanta determinazione
ma il mio obiettivo non riuscivo a
conseguirlo creiamo business e mi
fallivano lanciavo e falliva lanciavo e
falliva lanciava il falliva fila che è
un giorno mia moglie la mia più grande
famiglia
michele 6 sembra in start up dai forse
forse lo fa per te
è quella per me fu una pugnalata
perché non so se n'è mai capitato ma
quando la persona di cui tu hai più
fiducia
inizia a perdere fiducia nei suoi
confronti
inizio può
perdere il terreno sotto i piedi cui
tanto vicino così dal mollare tutto e
non inseguire il mio obiettivo
ma non lo fece
inizia a studiare in modo diverso per
cercare di capire cosa sto sbagliando
perché non raggiungo il mio obiettivo
cosa sto sbagliando pure le cose le so
sono bravo e inizia a studiare le cose
in modo completamente diverso a fare le
cose in modo completamente diverso e a
distanza di tempo sono diventato un
imprenditore la famiglia si è allargata
e ho la fortuna di lavorare con
40 persone che fanno parte del mio team
nel mio gruppo che lavorano con e
imprenditori quindi persone el aiutano
tutti i giorni a crescere quindi voglio
condividere con voi due aspetti il primo
è perché è così difficile cambiare il
secondo dal rì 5 suggerimenti che magari
vi saranno di ispirazione oggi per poter
migliorare il cambiamento verso i vostri
bettini
il cambiamento avviene quando ci sono
due elementi uno dei libri che mi ha più
di tutti ispirato è quello dello
psicologo jonathan science nel suo libro
ipotesi una felicità nel quale diceva
che quando vogliamo cambiare il nostro
lato razionale che ciò che pensiamo ci
permette di cambiare sia sufficiente ma
non è così serve un altro elemento dover
gestire che è il nostro elefante e il
nostro elefante nostro lato emotivo e
dovete immaginare che quando voleva
intraprendere un cambiamento è come se
dovessimo guidare un elefante
solo che lato razionale la guida è
nostro e fante hanno pregi e difetti
la guida al al pregio di essere
analitico progetta pianifica la visione
ma il difetto che ha un grande
procastinato re a tanta paura
molto spesso è bloccato da essa
dall'altra parte l'elefante è la forza
della natura è la vera energia che ci
porta verso quel cambiamento che
vogliamo ma dall'altra parte l'elefante
è difficile a guidare perché vuole la
soddisfazione immediata si perde in
tante cose e quindi se riusciamo a
combinare la nostra guida le nostre le
fante allora arriviamo a quel
cambiamento che desideriamo
quali sono le cinque regole che vi
possono aiutare a cambiare beh la prima
è molto semplice di circondarsi di
esperti di lasciarsi ispirare oggi si
siete qua è perché volevate arricchire
la vostra esperienza e tornare con
ispirazioni ma lo è un libero nella
formazione lo è una chiacchierata con
amici lo è circondarsi di persone che
hanno già raggiunto quel risultato che
voi volete ottenere nel 2002 a una cena
con amici a capodanno abbiamo detto dai
ragazzi ma perché non facciamo
l'esperienza della maratona ma sì dai da
domani partiamo va bene partiamo in
cinque
il giorno dopo era mentre dopo una
settimana ero da solo sì adesso mi sono
iscritto alla scuola agonistica di
rimini dove io
vivo e iniziai a frequentare persone che
avevano già fatto la maratona e gli
chiedevo ma che scarpe usi quale
l'abbigliamento qual è il programma
l'alimentazione e questo fu molto utile
perché aiuta la mia guida uno a creare
il progetto la visione ma numero due a
farmi coraggio perché se ce l'hanno
fatta loro potevo farcela anch'io
il secondo suggerimento è di creare un
progetto ma anche una cultura
occorre un progetto chiaro nel business
è palese che serve un progetto ben
definito ma lo serve anche se dovete
intraprendere un viaggio ma non un
viaggio una settimana organizzata un
vostro viaggio di quelli veri occorre
pianificarlo nei dettagli dovete
tranquillizzare la nostra guida
ma dall'altra parte sappiate già che
dovete mettere in conto che ci deve
essere anche una cultura dello sbagliare
e se volete inserire la in questo vostro
viaggio un vostro figlio un marito un
atteggiamento che magari non riuscita a
cambiarlo ma sta inseguendo questo
tipologia di progetto che avete voi
creato bene sappiate che sbaglierà non
penalizzate lo questo per esempio al mio
team di marketing della mia società come
vedete sembra una foto in cui sembrano
12 matti la realtà dei fatti che tutti i
giorni lavorano con grande impegno su
progetti ma c'era anche una cultura del
fallimento chi è che sbaglia chi fa
pensate che google permette i propri
collaboratori di fallire fino al 40 per
cento dei propri abiti in annuali perché
se tutti dovessero aggiungere al cento
per cento a vedere che non avrebbero
tarato gli obiettivi abbastanza in alto
terzo suggerimento mettete il pilota
automatico
perché ci sono centinaia di ricerche
scientifiche che testimoniano il fatto
che le nostre risorse mentali non sono
infinite
chi di noi magari più produttivo la
mattina chi magari più produttivo la
notte questo poco importa ma sappiate
che avete un tempo limitato mettere un
pilota automatico creando delle
abitudini ci porterà a farsi di andare
nella direzione quasi senza accorgersene
vi ricordate le prime volte quando
dovevate imparare a guidare
la cintura che la frizione lo
specchietto di adesso parto
adesso salite in macchina e partite e
andate in ufficio al lavoro senza
neanche più pensare quella il pilota
automatico e per farlo occorre saper
gestire il tempo ma non come pensano in
tanti
devo gestire il tempo il tempo è sempre
quello per tutti
dipende le azioni che facciamo per poter
gestire al meglio con delle trazioni
ovvero abitudini che ci portano in una
gestione migliore a posto delle
distrazioni che sono attività telefono
social che ci porta via tempo quindi
focalizzatevi sulle trazioni per creare
delle abitudini che vi portano a mettere
il pilota automatico io nomi si fanno
scrissi il mio primo libro in cui tutti
i giorni tutti i giorni sabato domenica
compresa
scrivevo due ore e l'ultima mezz'ora non
facevo altro che scrivere i punti che
dovevo scrivere il giorno dopo in modo
tale che quando tornavo non mi dovevo
riscaldare pensare cosa dovevo scrivere
magari farmi distrarre dai social dal
computer sapevo già cosa vuol fare e
scrisse un libro in 30 giorni
e finora qui siamo stati sulla guida ma
è l'elefante che fa la differenza
dovete cercare di capire qual è per voi
o per le persone che volete aiutare a
cambiare e magari vi ripeto possa essere
un figlio un marito una moglie un
collaboratore qual è la vera emozione
trainante qual è il vero perché
gli dicevo che io ho a che fare tutti i
giorni con imprenditori e gli
imprenditori più virtuosi non solo
quelli che vogliono crescere perché
semplicemente vogliono aumentare il
fatturato ma solo quelli che avevano
lasciare un'impronta nel mondo creare un
impatto sociale
sostenibile economico più ampio quello
il motivo vero
quando mi allenavo per la maratona tante
volte mi chiedo ma perché michele e di
ciò ma è uno il motivo principale
fu che ai tempi mio padre aveva un
brutto male che poi se lo portò via e
volevo allenarmi per poter fare la
maratona per poter dimostrare a lui
siamo veramente imparato la sua lezione
che era quella di non mollare mai
e la medaglia che presi quando poi feci
le maratone la regalare a lui per
dimostrargli quello che lui mi aveva
insegnato nella sua vita c'è sempre un
emozione che ci guida un'emulsione
trainante
e l'ultimo suggerimento è quello di
premiare l'elefante ad ogni passo perché
un grande cambiamento è fatto da piccoli
cambiamenti e ogni piccolo cambiamento
va premiato
quindi spezzettate ma premiate perché
così il vostro elefante sarà indirizzato
verso la direzione in cui vorrà questo
il mio cane si chiama brio e quando
insegnare a lui a tornare chiamandolo
per nome cosa facevo io devo dare un
biscottino e poi premiarlo bravo
bravissimo e lui imparò che alla parola
brio doveva tornare bene probabilmente
lo facciamo per chi di voi ha un cane
magari lo facciamo tanto con il cane ma
magari poco con i nostri figli con i
nostri collaboratori
dategli più bravo alimentate in loro
elefante
queste sono le
55 idee che hanno aiutato me ma
soprattutto che aiutano le persone a
poter cambiare noi le lato business ma
alla fine parliamo di persone ma ci sono
ulteriormente
33 pensieri credo e condividere con voi
il primo è quello legato alla l'avete
capito al saper gestire il cambiamento
considerando che dovete guidare le
vostre le fante
il secondo è legato al fatto di avere
più coraggio
recentemente è uscita un'intervista di
un'infermiera sulla posta che dichiarava
intervistava le persone sul letto di
morte e
le cinque ragioni sul letto di morte è
al primo posto le persone hanno
dichiarato non ho avuto abbastanza
coraggio di fare la vita che volevo
prendete più coraggio osate di più
cambiate lavoro se non vi piace provate
a seguire il vostro sogno fate quella
dichiarazione d'amore ma in seguite i
vostri sogni
ragionate fate con più coraggio
e l'ultimo è la maratona quella maratona
l'ho fatta e addirittura ho fatto una
maratona di new york e tra le maratone
di new york è la cosa più bella fu che
il giorno prima
di intraprendere a maratona
la ragazza che mi diede il
pettorale mi disse enjoy r miles of your
race che vuol dire goditi ogni singolo
miglio della tua corsa bene lo feci
davvero feci il mio peggior tempo tra le
maratone che ho fatto
ma è la maratona che mi sono divertito
di più come esperienza battevo il 5 le
persone
chiamavo camorra new york
sentivo
stato bellissimo
un'esperienza che porterò nel cuore come
esperienza di vita non come corsa e
questo lo voglio dire alle persone
che magari sono estremamente focalizzati
sull'obiettivo
ok va bene ma sappiate che nel percorso
succedono delle cose che alle volte sono
ancora più belle di quello che
l'obiettivo che avevamo in mente quindi
gestite le vostra guida non fatevi
fregare da essa gestito il vostro
elefante abbiate coraggio perché alla
fine i soldi vanno e vengono ma al tempo
no e per ultimo godetevi ogni singolo
passo del vostro cambiamento grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]